سارة تعاني من إصابات
في جمجمتها ورئتيها وذراعها وساقها ،
لكن الأطباء يقولون إن الأسوأ هو
الشظايا المتعددة التي
استقرت في عمودها الفقري والحبل الشوكي ،
وقالت عمة سارة
والأطباء يخشون أنها قد لا تتكرر أبدًا
خاصة إذا بقيت.
هنا تقول العائلة إنه لم يكن هناك
تحذير مسبق قبل الإضراب
، ليس لديهم أي فكرة عما سيحدث
[موسيقى]
وهذا ما يسميه شقيقها الأكبر عمر
إنها بحاجة إلى مركز جراحة أعصاب متقدم
ليس لدينا أطباء في غزة
قالوا إن هناك أملًا في ذلك
ستكون قادرة على الوقوف على قدميها ،
يقول والدها ظاهر
إنه يتوسل للمساعدة
إنه يريد لطفلة صغيرة أن
تستعيد حياتها حياة مليئة بصرخات
الفرح المبهجة حياة حيث يمكنها الوقوف بمفردها
إنها تكافح نفسياً
والدها  تقول إنها لا تزال تسألني
لماذا أبي لماذا فعلوا
هذا بي
أروى دامون سيينا